The best, most effective commercials leave
a lasting impression on the consumer Ñ but
sometimes, brands take things too far É which
brings even more attention to the commercial,
and thus the brand, encouraging envelope-pushing
in the industry.
Here are a few examples of banned commercial
spots from across the globe.
Bar gets barred
Israeli supermodel Bar Refaeli has starred
in two commercials deemed too steamy for prime
time in her home country.
One for clothing company Hoodies in 2016 is
basically a Sports Illustrated swimsuit issue
spread come-to-life.
But the original cut lingered too long on
Bar's behind and implied she was bottomless
at one point, so it was censored by Israel's
version of the FCC.
But even the censored version was too much:
the tamer spot still couldn't air until after
10 p.m.
This wasn't the first time a Bar-starring
spot got barred from prime time: In 2014,
she co-starred in another Hoodies commercial
with a mustachioed Muppet É and two other
versions of herself É which was said to
have Òtoo many sexual insinuationsÓ É
ÒYou just canÕt enough of me, huh?Ó
Giving up the gun
In 2005, Microsoft cooked up a commercial
they knew would cause a commotion, so they
effectively "pre-banned" it in the US, allowing
only a limited audience of "hardcore" gamers
to see it.
The playful Xbox 360 spot featuring strangers
engaging in a sprawling finger-gun shoot-out
in the middle of a busy terminal never aired
on television and was only shown at promotional
events.
ÒBoom!
Boom!Ó
ÒAh!Ó
Once the ad leaked, the Internet speculated
wildly about why the spot wasn't given a wider
release, leading to rumors about network or
FCC bans over its violent content É but
it was simply Microsoft thinking outside the
Xbox.
No apologies
In a weird twist in 2014, a SodaStream Super
Bowl spot featuring Scarlett Johansson about
what it takes for a video to go viral ended
up going viral É but for an entirely different
reason than the one depicted in the video.
The spot showcases how easy it is to use the
device to create a soda that's better for
the consumer and the environment É but then
ScarJo decides that stripping down to a slinky
dress and sipping on her soda seductively
is what's needed to achieve viral stardom
"Sorry, Coke and Pepsi."
"Oh yeah, she done it.
SodaStream!"
Ironically, the ploy wasn't even given a chance
to work, since FOX rejected the spot over
the mocking apology to SodaStream's competitors.
But the controversy drew millions of eyeballs
to the "uncensored" spot with the offending
line ... as well as the otherwise identical
"censored" spot during the big game.
Sorry, Coke and Pepsi.
Dead to rights
This 2001 Dutch commercial for the Hyundai
Veloster featured the personification of Death
itself coming to claim a soul É and the
shockingly brutal way Death gets it done ...
Ouch.
It's a good thing the Veloster only has three
doors, a Death-defying safety feature meant
to cut down on such accidents.
Interestingly, the spooky spot was actually
shot down by Hyundai itself before airing
for being "too shocking" for their brand.
But like a lot of these banned ads, it lives
on in infamy.
Trap house
Speaking of disturbingly violent images, how
about this shocking 2006 commercial from New
Zealand for the Toyota RAV4?
The car is so amazing, apparently, that it
turns husband and wife against each other
in their shared quest to drive it.
They set cartoonish, Home Alone-style traps
to try to slow the other down while they go
through their morning routine.
Viewers complained it "sent an inappropriate
message to children," was "not socially responsible,"
and it "would encourage similar behavior"
É so the popular ad was yanked from the
airwaves.
For heaven's sake
This slick 2011 Axe Excite spot features skimpily-dressed
angels falling from heaven and giving up their
immortality to hook up with a dude that wears
a spray-on deodorant.
ÒMama mia.Ó
The supposedly sacrilegious TV spot was banned
by South Africa's Advertising Standards Authority
for "offending members of the Christian faith"
É a move that surely increased the number
of curious Christians watching the spot online
Ñ a devil of a predicament for censors.
Indecent exposure
In 2007, Bud Light created a cheeky commercial
featuring a carefree couple tossing off their
clothes and going skinny-dipping, assuming
they're alone ...
ÒBartender!
Bud Light!Ó
Oops.
The spot was supposed to air during the Super
Bowl that year, but was rejected by CBS.
The ban, however, led to even more exposure
for Budweiser, since it made headlines, generating
tens of millions of views online, and giving
it a much longer shelf life Ñ like being
featured in videos like this one, ten years
later.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!